je découvre le jeu c'est un Mordelles
pas possible on va pas se raconter une
histoire un bon merci d'être là les
chéris vous adorez les cheveux là dans
le
l'enceinte de l'établissement regardez
comme c'est beau la photo de docteur
mais dans le cinoche le cinéma regardez
regardez Alain Delon
et ma grand-mère là
bon les chéris merci d'être là c'est
très simple on va jouer ensemble
vous avez eu on profite du beau temps
parce que oui vous l'avez compris au
profit du beau temps maintenant
on est dedans donc on profite du beau
temps on est dedans donc c'est très
simple vous l'avez compris on va jouer
au flecht ça veut dire c'est comme
réfléchettes mais avec des shottes c'est
très simple ici il y a des chottes de
vinaigre shots de poisson pourri shot de
piment shot de la culotte à Daniel
elle est ici
anaïster maman ramenez-moi une serviette
et donc vous tirez par exemple c'est
très simple et vous pouvez donc tirer
une fléchette sur la personne qui ne va
boire un shot vous voulez que je vous
fasse un exemple voilà je tire par
exemple voilà je vais tirer
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
si je fais ça
donc Gilles tu dois boire un shot tu
vois ou pas d'accord donc retour vous
voulez que
Guillaume voilà
pardon
c'est dur c'est dur hein
là c'est l'exemple là c'est l'exemple
alors j'ai comme vous voulez ou bien je
joue que moi
je pense que c'est moi je pense que le
mieux c'est en effet trois fraîches on a
plus de chance
votre chef
donnez-moi
chef qui joue
qui joue contre moi on fait sur cinq
tirs celui qui fait le plus de ballon
après il tire et il a il a droit à 5
pochettes pour faire les trucs
où tu peux piquer ainsi s'achète à
Benaim
parce que Guillaume m'a dit qu'il était
plutôt transformé la pression contre
Siri c'est de gagner des heures
benjama tu te prends ce que c'est plus
fort ou pas tu choisis qui allez
Benjamin toi il est aveugle
c'est derrière ça si vous jouez avancer
allez
pas mal
on l'a dit Delphine
allez c'est parti on a donc
on a donc 5 flèches chacun
tu te mets derrière attention tu
démarres vas-y démarre et après on aura
5 fléchettes pour choisir
[Applaudissements]
doucement Benji
[Musique]
il
est nul
merci Monsieur
[Applaudissements]
non mais je suis très fort
à toutes les conneries je suis très fort
donc ça c'est très simple je vais
maintenant voir 5 fléchettes ok ok je
vais donc maintenant ballon pas ballon
dès que je tire sur un truc c'est je
choisis un shot pour quelqu'un ok donc
là je vais tirer pour une première
personne qui va boire un shot de
vinaigre d'accord attention c'est parti
et s'ambiance
[Applaudissements]
ça va
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
attention les gars le pire là là on va
jouer pour le choc de poisson pourri
attention
c'est entre les deux
[Musique]
tu dois désigner quelqu'un je l'offre
avec plaisir à Benjamin
[Rires]
oh là là là là
la musique ne veut rien dire
[Musique]
à partir de maintenant je vais lancer un
nouveau jeu vous allez lancer une
fléchette chacun votre tour
si vous touchez un ballon vous êtes
sauvé si vous ne touchez pas de ballon
vous buvez ok attention c'est parti
venez près de moi attention c'est parti
on démarre avec Raymond si vous touchez
c'est bon si vous perdez c'est vous vous
buvez attention c'est parti
[Applaudissements]
ce que tu veux vinaigre
voilà allez-y vinaigre attention
allez c'est pas vrai courage
allez c'est dégueulasse
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
attention à l'envers nouveau jeu
maintenant
je vais faire maintenant des fléchettes
on me retourne
si j'en mets trois sur cinq ok d'accord
trois ballons sur 5
vous avez le droit de repartir
tranquillement au sud ok si non si j'en
mets trois sur cinq vous buvez tout le
reste
toute la
table c'est bien tout le monde
en revanche on est bien d'accord que si
par exemple Raymond vous battre vous
buvez vous la table
attention c'est parti tu vois quel
morceau
j'ai besoin
d'un mort
oh
[Applaudissements]
non
regarde regarde regarde
comme il fait
[Applaudissements]
tu es nul
le encore une fois
c'est terminé la troisième bien sûr
concentration
[Applaudissements]
merci
je vais en faire une maintenant on
retournement
si je la mets il reste plus le ballon en
plus c'est moins 100 balles pour tout le
monde
à chaque fois et si vous la mettez pas
si je la mets pas c'est plus dix balles
pour tout le monde
[Rires]
c'est plus 100 balles pour tout le monde
je le fais en retournement par contre
c'est trois fléchettes
[Rires]
si jamais d'ici c'est pareil quand on
retournement frère
[Musique]
[Rires]
je regarde l'heure j'ai un rendez-vous
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
c'est celui qui a pas d'argent qui parie
combien bah je sais pas 2 2
direct hein non non non non non non
[Musique]
ça se rapproche
[Applaudissements]
vas-y c'est fait
emmenez-moi 5 fléchettes
toujours en 5
[Applaudissements]
bonjour
en deux fléchettes non non c'est pas
sérieux
je vais changer de billet toi
[Applaudissements]
j'ai besoin d'argent
merci Sacha merci
est-ce que vous voulez faire est-ce que
vous voulez faire
je dois mettre trois ballons ok
entre nous deux vas-y ok en trois
fléchettes en trois fléchettes
[Rires]
attention
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
calme
dans ta poche
du public là faut faire gagner le public
la Galise
on est bleu
égalité
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
pour les Bleus ça fait 200 pour le
public alors
tu perds ton slip non perdons
[Applaudissements]
ma grand-mère ta grand-mère
et pourquoi c'est pour toi mamie
à droite il a passé c'est
là je vais la mettre là je fais la
mettre
c'est fini tu me dois 100 balles
merci merci
[Applaudissements]